elle était redoutée elle est finalement
sur le point d'arriver
la deuxième vague de kobe 19 se profile
à travers le monde
après un bilan de plus de neuf cent
vingt mille morts et 29 millions de
personnes contaminées pour anticiper une
aggravation de la crise sanitaire
certains états prennent les devants
deuxième pays au monde avec le plus de
cas par habitant enregistrées sur les
deux dernières semaines
israël a décidé d'instaurer un
confinement nationale de trois semaines
une décision prise par le premier
ministre netanyahu aujourd'hui lors de
la réunion du gouvernement
nous avons pris une décision sur leur
immense rict de confinement pour trois
semaines
car avec une possibilité de prolongation
vu au bras mais chut mm ce jeudi ils ont
agité un drapeau rouge
les cadres du ministère de la santé et
directeurs d'hôpitaux nous ont averti
que les taux de mortalité impose
l'application de mesures immédiates
une partie du personnel médical et des
hôpitaux est débordé les autorités ont
annoncé que ce confinement obligatoires
entrera en vigueur ce vendredi jour du
nouvel an juif
il prendra fin au mieux aux alentours du
9 octobre ce qui fait débat puisque les
fête juive de yom kippour et souccot
auront lieu durant cette période
d'isolement
le premier ministre israélien a tout de
même précisé que les prières avec 10
personnes maximum seront autorisés dans
les lieux fermés et 20 personnes maximum
dans les lieux ouverts depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire
israël a recensé plus de 1120 morts et
près de 150 mille cas de kobe de 19